[Music]
you are playing the Punisher if you can
see and it's funny because it's it's a
role that people have experiment with
before but it never seemed to quite gel
and and it's a lot of responsibility
when you take on you know people really
love the Punisher I think a lot of fans
of the Punisher and then you take on
this role and in this comics universe
fans take that really seriously like
don't screw this up yeah yeah absolutely
I mean look I've said before it's a it's
a it's a it's a character that's
resonated deeply with members of law
enforcement in the military and that's
something I take super seriously along
with the comic-book fans and I'll tell
you as far as the comic book fans are
concerned one of the one of the sort of
true pleasures for me in this was the
research and going all over the country
going from comic book store to comic
book store and just just eating up as
much of this as I possibly could do they
with their heads explode if you walk
into a comic book store and these are
people that some of them like the
Punishers their favorite character and
they know that you're gonna play The
Punisher and then Jon Bernthal walks in
what's it like well it completely
depends on where you are because I'll
tell you I remember right after it sort
of became when they announced that I was
gonna be playing the part I went to a
comic book store in Ventura and there's
a guy he's smoking a cigarette there's
no one in the store he was sitting
outside he's like can I help you and he
didn't even look up and I said yeah man
I'm just looking for some Punisher
comics you know he's like yeah we don't
have much since the announcement I'm
like announce me I'm like that's that's
me
that's my announcement I'm like wow
that's cool and so then I'm like do I be
like a total douche and go over to the
guy but yeah actually I'm the guy you
know and I'm so I just say hey man if
you could and then he looked up and he
said oh it's you and he was so cool he
was so helpful he said you need to read
this this and this and he gave it to me
for free and I was it was just so cool
but then I went to New York yeah I go
into a comic book store in Brooklyn and
I go in and you know I get a whole stack
and I go up to buy him and he looks at
me goes yeah I know who you are I go ok
cool man I just want to buy these comics
he goes no you don't you're not taking
this you're not taking this you're not
taking this you need to read this this
this and this and I was like ok dude and
he's like do not mess this up my god
if you get it for free no man you're
gonna pay extra and it's pronounced puny
sure
[Laughter]
you